[Music]
I looked in my riew mirror
and it seemed to make a lot more
sense and what I see a hat of us a hat
of
yeah I'm ready to make that
turn before we both crash and
M cuz that could be the death of us the
death of us baby you know how to drive
it rain you decided not to make a change
stuck in the same old Lane go in the
wrong way home I feel like my heart is
stuck in bum bu traffic I'm B pressure
cuz I can't have you the way that I want
can we go back to the way
you
honeymon
avue
honeymon UE my baby coasting like crazy
can we get back to the way it
was
yeah what happened to the
butterfli guess they encountered that
stop
sign cuz my heart is at a yellow light a
yellow light
oh right when I think that we found it
well that's when we start turning around
you're saying baby don't worry
but we're still going the wrong way baby
you know how to drive it rain you
decided not to make a change stuck in
the same old Lane going in the wrong way
home I feel like my heart is stuck in
bumper bum tra I'm under pressure cuz I
can't have you the way that I want
can we go back to way it
was
honeymon knew
honey AV knew my baby coasted like crazy
and we go back to the way it
was oh they say only fools fall in love
but they must have been talking about us
and some sometimes I feel like I've been
here
before yeah I could be wrong but I know
that I'm right we going to be lost if we
continue to fight honey I know
yeah we can find our way
home I feel like my heart is stuck in
bumper the bum traffic I'm under
pressure cuz I can't hand you the way
that I want can we go back to the way it
was we were on honey moon
avue
honeymon avue my baby coasting like
crazy can we get back to the way it
was on
honeymoon never knew
honeymon never knew my baby coasting
like crazy can we get back to the way
you
[Music]
are
H
oh
yeah honey
[Music]
moon